[Music]
right welcome to the most amazing
upper peninsula we're on the edge of uh
lake superior i've just gone up against
one of the most talented chefs in
america
james ricardo and i'm here to give you a
little insight to
some comfort foods i'm going to do a
beautiful sort of
smoke trout melt now this is a local
trout
it's been smoked this morning and it's
so
delicious now how do we turn that into
something a little bit more exciting
when i get the bread literally just
on there lightly drizzle it with a touch
of olive oil
lightly salt that okay the trout has
been smoked
lightly okay bring that over here get
that toasting
put the bread in there and get that
beautifully
toasting in there get that nice and
crispy that's the base okay
really important get that nice and firm
you'll see why now look at this trap
look at that i'm gonna pry that open
there
and just flake that into your bowl look
beautiful
don't mush it up okay it's nice and
moist
and the secret there is to keep it
really nice
and flaky okay take your lemon
start grating in there
okay take your knife
slice that onion down now i'm putting
onion in there you can put a little bit
of caper in there if you wish
but a red onion less harsh than the
white onion
a lot more flavoursome now this
there's some little fennel prongs inside
and just
open them up and pick them in there
and get your lemon
squeeze that in there okay
a nice large spoon of creme fraiche
in okay and then just give that a nice
little mix
now don't over mix it keep it nice
and sort of gently in the fold okay
really important let's get our bread
toast that over and look at that
beautiful
it's exactly what we want now from there
bring that back
and this is where we start dressing it
now
generously and because we haven't ever
whipped this
you'll see that real nice sort of
caramelization going on now
and that's why it's important to gently
fold that
okay on top beautiful
now from there a light season of some
fresh pepper
a little touch of salt okay
and then just get that cheddar
cheese on there okay and this
is where the magic starts this is where
we start
to melt that beautiful cheese season the
top of the cheese as well
salt and pepper again okay
and then from there well on
to your grill and then literally
get your pan and place that on there
and give that literally two minutes now
whilst that's going
get your pan nice and hot again a little
touch
of olive oil in
a little touch of butter and
i've got a little touch of garlic
okay and that's comfy garlic roasted
slowly that's going to go in
to my oil and then get my eggs
and crack my eggs in there nice and
gently
okay nice and gently in
get that garlic out now because it's
done its magic has infused
my eggs okay back over
on as they start to bubble
literally check this out look at that
beautiful beautiful
back down again now the idea here he's
got that nice rich creamy
smoked cheddar that nice fragrant
lightly smoked lake trout and i've got a
nice rustic
beautiful egg on top give that egg a
little season
get that beautifully done nice
those eggs in there as that butter
starts getting nice and brown it's that
wonderful flavor on those eggs
i want to baste those eggs so get the
pan
and tilt and just cook the middle
there you go and that gets those
whites beautifully cooked the butters go
nice and brown
and it cooks the eggs beautifully
now first off bring over the melts
look at that beautiful
so good
so delicious the bread
is nice and firm but
it's all about the finishing and what
goes well with fish
eggs and look at these just frothing in
that beautiful brown butter
lift that up give it a little shake
a little dab and sit that
on top and again
shake and up and look
that is how you eat out in the wild
beautiful a lake trout
melt finished with a fried egg
and delicious now if you enjoyed that
recipe please click the link below and
if you missed uncharted
then please watch on catch up on disney
plus